all right 6 26 on your wednesday morning
even if this was the only thing i talked
about
every single day forever it probably
wouldn't change much and it's not just
driving me crazy it's driving viewer
marianne crazy too she writes
please tell drivers to use their blinker
juice
i thought all cars now have blinkers but
i see way too many cars not using them i
remember when we had to use hand signals
now it's so easy
is it lazy are they on the phone
i wish i knew mary anne but i will go
ahead and be optimistic and hope against
hope
that mentioning it again for the
bajillio time
just might maybe sink into the skull of
even one
offending driver you know what it's not
just intersections too
how about how amazed you might be at the
difference you see when you signal that
you're about to
change lanes wow
well my wife reposted a facebook picture
from the popular npr car talk shows page
it's an overhead sign must be from the
boston area
you ya blinker got it okay
rant over buckle up drive carefully
please put down that phone if there's
something driving you crazy email me
traffic eight eight news now dot com